and vladimir putin set to meet june 16th
in geneva switzerland
with no preconditions so is the media
going to accuse
biden of being a kgb agent what about
the colonial pipeline hack
here's the white house defending it
don't regard the meeting with the
russian president as a reward we regard
it
as a vital part of defending america's
interests uh and president biden is
meeting
with vladimir putin because of our
country's differences not in spite of
them
were there any preconditions no and
remember how joe biden approved that
huge giveaway to russia
by dropping sanctions against the
pipeline that goes to germany
the president now spinning it as not
really a big deal
it's almost completed by the time i took
off
and uh to go ahead and close sanctions
now
that i think is counterproductive in
terms of our european relations
all right dana you're probably familiar
with a few of these big
high-level meetings how do these things
happen and should there have been
preconditions in your opinion
well probably not um although there
might be some in private i mean you can
you can kind of have your own
right for you for going but this will be
their first chance to meet as
president biden and then putin i imagine
that putin's like
yeah what do you got you know i'll i can
outlast you
and he in putin's mind he's running
circles
around america and especially on this
north stream too like i get it that it's
almost finished but like the keystone
pipeline
was something where you didn't want to
upset your european allies but what
about your neighbor to the north
right where the canadians do justin
trudeau is up there like wait hello
i mean we were going to have this and if
the issue is climate change
the climate is a global issue right so
the pipeline is there anyway
uh this meeting will be highly
scrutinized
and for all the people who suggested
president trump wasn't tough enough on
russia
when you actually look at the facts
coming out of this summit meeting
that i think will be a very interesting
comparison
last thing is i wouldn't have called it
a summit why because i think that makes
it too grand
yeah i would have said we're gonna get
together for coffee
[Laughter]
and that's it yeah maybe some orange
gatorade juan how about
little uh orange gatorade with vlad
well i think you know to me it's not
like trump meeting with kim jong-un with
no preconditions all kim jong-un wanted
uh was the meeting guess that put him as
on the world stage as a world leader
um and in this case nobody doubts that
vladimir putin is a leader of a
powerful nation but i think going into
this it's biden who has the upper hand i
mean clearly
putin bet on trump in 16 he won he
doubled down in 20 then he lost came up
snake eyes now
what's biden going to do biden's going
to say what about that colonial pipeline
hack
ha vlad what about that what about
election interference
vladimir putin what about the way that
you treat dissidents what about amassing
troops
on the border in ukraine all of that is
not something that vladimir putin wants
to talk about you certainly don't want
to talk about it with someone who has
the power
of joe biden in terms of the economic
power that we can exert over russia well
i agree with that we always have the
upper hand as america but
he already cleared him greg he said
putin had nothing to do with the hack
and let him off the hook
you know what's interesting is when
the outgoing president obama met with
donald trump
he told him that the most vital urgent
threat facing the united states was
north korea
north korea which we don't even talk
about anymore
and why is that because of that no
precondition meeting that trump had with
kim jong-un which removed a
psychological barrier and a
psychological threat
from our country we all remember what
happened in hawaii people thought they
were going to die
we don't even talk about it anymore
literally scratch that off the list
of urgent threats that's pretty amazing
that would have won any democrat a nobel
prize but of course
what does putin have on joe biden
considering that hunter biden's actual
real life
makes the steel dossier sound like
winnie the pooh
or shall i say winnie the p so i think
clearly putin has biden
in his pocket joe could be a russian
asset perhaps a manchurian candidate
maybe even mentally ill we should
consider that what is the 25th amendment
uh and i'd like to quote rachel maddow
where is constantine kalimnik tick tick
tick tick boom
yeah and your point after that meeting
for three years north korea didn't test
a long-range missile
or or a major major atom bomb all right
degan
so big expectations for this meeting
because i have a feeling the media is
going to just make joe look like
g.i joe
yeah they will try but in terms of the
timing
not just the colonial pipeline hack it's
not just the gift to russia
in the pipeline into germany what about
the immense lukashenko
is putin's proxy in belarus the wall
street journal editorial page wrote
about this
who forced a plane to land in minsk and
then
took captive a journalist who is said to
be
tortured right now so the timing does
look like a reward
a gift a giant cake wrapped in a box
with a huge
bow on it what's biden going to say to
putin
cut it out which is what obama said to
him about the
election interference and one more thing
joe biden called putin a killer
so why is he so anxious to sit down next
to a murderer
um we will find out pretty soon
on june 16th in the lovely country of
switzerland
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else